welcome to this video and I'm chin to
which Z guha byung byung song okay so
let's see if wins gambit yeah the
triangle I always play Quincy to him
maybe I should just find some change of
flavor look at something else but I'm
really scoring with it quite well age 6
yeah I'm wondering yeah this is kind of
normal but Queen fif is irritating me at
the moment but ok is not he's not trying
to use this in any way he just just just
content with going to a bad Queens
gambit declined this is a bad version of
the Queens gambit declined let's see you
if you go b6 like in the Tata Culver you
have no need to play c6 is simply simply
a weird combination of moves ok I can
play various things here this is this is
a very similar solution like maybe not
the best one but it is it is simple and
it is not bad at all ok Bishop d3 just
um if he if he allows I will go for the
pillsbury information with 95 f & F for
I have done that on on a video I think
mmhmm yeah 95 immediately or rook t1 and
like look to you one also putting the
rook opposite the Queen which is very
often a big issue for black in those
structures then Queen has no good place
to go yeah this is just putting a little
bit more pressure on him it's bit
difficult for black now to untangle
maybe move like night h5 was interesting
now that I think of it okay so who 95
this isn't this very annoying I'm going
for that okay well it didn't look good
anyway but Luke's the eight mmm-hmm
tough decision okay can I do something
drastic probably not but f-for is just
good anyway now we really can never take
on e5 as the FR will open up yeah will
be different difficult difficult
position here um how do I get more
higher power Brooke f3 some something
like that or you know many many possible
ways it really is a very comfortable
position sometimes even if for is an
idea I have no direct way to to punish
him I think yeah maybe rook f3 but it's
not so clear what this is aiming for
okay 3g three I don't know i'll play it
I'll play it anyway
that is quite amazing that this should
be possible with all the white pieces
get pin against the center and maybe it
is and it probably is yeah cakes i can
even take with the bishop it's not that
bad yeah Luke f3 I was a little bit a
little bit unsure about this move and
probably justifiably sound alright it's
not that bad look like Luke f3 was
really bad this does not fit in in the
position at all how do i play that now I
probably have to do this d well before
no looks really weird okay the time ah
the time spent is crazy here what I'm
doing really crazy time management okay
sticking with the pawn
Joe do you form
and with d5 divorce is coming in but
what what the heck did i do here wow I
really have to check this afterwards I
mean this is it was a completely
unplayable position for black and then
screwed up in four moves that's not so
easy he was probably technically
technically bad but you know what about
this F 797 when I had an idea with the
move it's not like I had no idea I was
more concerned about other things I mean
it looked very shaky don't know what's
going on now I mean f7 is hanging and
the bend the bishop of course time
warning here check mate on g7 what are
you doing against that now
I can just take it I can just take it
check
maybe this wasn't the most precise move
all around yeah you can he can sacrifice
the Queen now we didn't check check
check yeah that was very lucky I really
screwed this up completely after he
played this really totally unplayable
opening it's kind of a funny expression
playing an unplayable opening yeah this
is this is really just terribly bad for
black but here I simply this is this is
a total joke move rook f3 edit I mean it
kind of happens in this position yeah
way that you lift the rook here but it
simply didn't now now stop which is
giving the move ah that's funny I still
don't like it I still don't like it the
restore ish once rook f3 yeah but I
still this is a good move yeah it still
likes the movie and give us a ride 0.8 i
actually had thought i should have more
but it's just 0.8 the computer wants to
do this and then drop back to f2 which
is kind of weird but it wants to go here
i am yeah well white is certainly better
on I mean black has lost tons of time
Eric c8 and back end and this kind of
thing now there's also the idea to play
you for you which is an idea that I had
in the game but I never really got to do
that he played here and stockfish wants
to take on c5 ha and since white is just
better yeah I just played all the combos
it looks like a totally cheating game
but I thought at three thought I'm I'm
struggling here take sandy foyer and it
gives white a big advantage ha i was
thinking that here there should be
something because it looks
no it looks kind of shaky with this and
and everything yeah but but I mean
stockfish doesn't see anything it gives
white pretty clear advantage with 0.8
and this losers yeah I'm here queen bee
three and and and over probably add
something quicker even night a form ok
but this winds right again night a for
but I don't really think that the
shooting Chang check yeah yeah I thought
you would do that trying to hang on with
this but I mean it is really it is too
much material right yeah okay this is
also trapped bit of a coincidence but
this is strapped I can do this and now
this thing is going next move okay yeah
auntie em check it is just the just the
checkmate checkmate yeah I was really
lucky here because of the time
management and okay three it probably
wasn't that bad then but I couldn't
really find I still don't like the movie
it still looked like it I was kind of I
was a bit irritated that I didn't see a
natural good continuation because it's
like everything's perfect now for white
but somehow it's not nothing as
materializing could I maybe have done
something better but it's all the and
playing first move or stock fish to the
whole time it really looks like i'm
cheating rookie one Bishop f5 is
stockfish rupee 895 engine correlation
one hundred percent great yeah well okay
then it was probably a good game but I
had my doubts as you noticed during the
live commentary okay well thanks for
watching